here with lavon ardonian levon it didn't
seem like much happened today but
certainly you were trying where did it
go wrong
you mean those blizzards and thunders
did not impress you
yeah you know i i mean
you're a foreign place you should before
check you should normally play knight
bd2
but since i didn't expect it i thought
well i gotta
just play solid you know uh
i think i had a difficult game yesterday
so i was trying to just you know not to
blunt her talk to us about yesterday it
seemed like you came under pressure in
one of your favorite lines what happened
there
i mixed up
fifth move which is
i mean uh just speaks for itself
certainly nothing
but you held that game you felt that you
were under a lot of pressure how did you
evaluate it in the middle of the game
yeah i thought uh it's a very difficult
position and
i was
very angry at myself
but
yeah
somehow it's not a blitz i'm not gonna
blunder pieces so
i just relaxed and
defended of course it's
not a great way to start
but held the draw there now draw against
magnus carlsen how are you taking this
tournament we know that you've been
playing back to back to back events in
india miami you're here now how do you
feel physically and what are your
perspectives towards the rest of this
thing field um
yeah i got sick in india and i'm still
kind of still recovering i really don't
feel uh
particularly well but
you know will
i mean
i
always overcome and
i will do it this time as well i'm sure
so
it just takes time to to find the form
absolutely well a magician on and off
the board leonardo will let you rest up
for the remaining of the tournament
thank you for joining us thank you no we
won't no we won't yeah
he said magnus said it was a critical
and he's gone and he's gone and he's
gone